these are disappearing globalists they
are very important for the survival of
the entire human race and people don't
realize how bad the situation is
I'm not scare off the beast what's the
worst thing that can happen one thing is
that the DS won't climb on me and that
will be really ashamed and the second
thing is that they will sting me I'm a
big tipper I've been a big eater my
entire life so that's not something new
for me I'm terrified of the dance I'm
supposed to do because I'm really a bad
dancer and you need to go on the catwalk
with the DS and that's the like the
scariest part of the competition for me
I I got about 18 things it says quite
different than what I expected
I wasn't expecting the bees to be so
warm